This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好！你们正在收听的是由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都觉得不太安全但却坦诚的对话，而和你对话的是一位经验丰富的持证专业人士。有多少男人身上披着铠甲。这向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。这并不意味着你有这种能力就必须要使用它，收听
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Learn the Hard Way。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。大批网络侦探花了很长时间才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he did.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的法则。经历一些困难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己迎来柳暗花明。收听《2%》。即iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方上的T-W-O-P-E-R-C-E-N-T。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他所做之事的。
deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is great to have you here back for another episode. Today, we are talking about something I think all of us have struggled with at some point in our lives. And that is why we are so hard on ourselves. Like all the time, it feels like this is the generation of self-criticism.
应有的下场。我们总是说要相信你的好姐妹。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们二十多岁的重大生活变化与转型及其对心理学意义的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目。今天，我们要聊聊一个我认为我们所有人都在生命中的某个时刻挣扎过的话题。那就是为什么我们对自己如此苛刻。仿佛无时无刻不在苛求自己，感觉这就是一个自我批评的时代。
as humans and I think particularly in our 20s, we're often our harshest critics. We tirelessly scrutinize every little decision, every action, every outcome in our lives. Why am I such a failure? Why did I say that? Why don't I look like them? I must be doing something wrong and we constantly strive for perfection, expecting ourselves to reach these impossible standards that we've never really held for anyone else in our lives. But I think it's really interesting to examine why we put ourselves through this. What kind of drives this inner critic and this relentless pursuit of being flawless or perfect? The other irony of self-criticism that I find really fascinating, but also a bit disturbing or
作为人类，我尤其认为在我们二十多岁的时候，我们常常是自己最严厉的批评者。我们不知疲倦地审视着生活中的每一个小决定、每一个行动、每一个结果。为什么我这么失败？我为什么要那样说？为什么我长得不像他们？我一定是什么地方做错了，我们不断地追求完美，期待自己达到那些我们从未对生活中的任何人真正抱有的不可能达到的标准。但我觉得去审视我们为什么要经历这一切真的很有趣。究竟是什么在驱动着这个内在的批评者，以及对无瑕或完美的这种无休止的追求？自我批评的另一个讽刺之处，我觉得既非常着迷，但也有些令人不安或
interesting, is that we speak to ourselves in a way that we would never dream of doing so to others. So why do we find it so hard to give ourselves the same grace, the same love, the same forgiveness that we give people like our family, like our friends, like our partners? So today, we are going to peel back the layers of our inner critic and examine some of the evolutionary, biological, social roots of why we are so hard on ourselves. A lot of the theory says that it may actually come down to survival, whereby we are overly self-critical to avoid stepping out of line or acting against a societal norm so that we can be accepted. Or in the case of things like self-deprecating humour, we use that to make ourselves feel and seem more agreeable or to mask our insecurities
有趣的是，我们对自己说话的方式，是我们做梦也绝不会对别人那样做的。那么，为什么我们发现要给予自己和对待家人、朋友、伴侣那样同样的宽容、同样的爱、同样的谅解是如此困难呢？所以今天，我们将剥开内心批评者的层层面纱，审视我们对自己如此苛刻的进化、生物和社会根源。许多理论表明，这实际上可能归结于生存，即我们过度地进行自我批评，以避免出格或违背社会规范，从而能够被接纳。或者在像自嘲幽默这样的情况下，我们用它来让自己感觉并显得随和一些，或者来掩饰我们的不安全感
and protect ourselves. It all kind of comes down to, at the end of the day, our existence as social creatures and further to that of course our childhood. The words spoken to us as children, either by parents, by peers, by teachers, they become the words we speak to ourselves as adults. And a lot of that has to do with feeling like we need to earn love. We need to earn support to earn the good things in our lives and be absolutely perfect or else we're not worth that kind of treatment. So let's discuss.
并保护我们自己。归根结底，这一切都归结于我们作为社会生物的存在，除此之外，当然还有我们的童年。小时候对我们说的话，无论是父母、同龄人还是老师说的，都成了我们成年后对自己说的话。这其中很大一部分与感觉我们需要赢得爱有关。我们需要赢得支持来获得生活中的美好事物，并且必须绝对完美，否则我们就不配得到那种对待。所以让我们来讨论一下。
We're going to talk about the origins of this nasty inner critic, but also how we can silence that inner voice. This episode, it's not about dwelling in the negativity. It's about gaining awareness, embracing vulnerability, and ultimately, I think, finding compassion for ourselves amidst all of our imperfections. I also really want to deep dive into some pretty, I would say, innovative, new therapeutic practices that have come about recently, including radical self-compassion and cognitive diffusion. These are both amazing practices and skills that can help us kind of silence that little mean voice in our head. I'm really keen for this episode. I hope you are too.
我们将讨论这个讨厌的内在批评者的起源，以及我们如何能够让那个内心的声音安静下来。这一期节目不是为了沉溺于负面情绪中。而是为了获得觉醒，拥抱脆弱，归根结底，我认为是在我们所有的不完美中找到对自己的同情。我也真的很想深入探讨一些非常具有创新性的、近来兴起的全新治疗实践，包括激进的自我同情和认知解离。这些都是了不起的实践和技巧，可以帮助我们让我们脑海中那个刻薄的小声音安静下来。我非常期待这一期节目。希望你也是。
So without further ado, let's get into the psychology behind why we are so hard on ourselves. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
话不多说，让我们进入关于为什么我们对自己如此苛刻的心理学探讨。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的法则。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以抛开主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio. app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些困难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己迎来柳暗花明。收听《2%》。即iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方上的T-W-O-P-E-R-C-E-N-T。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击利尔·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟利尔·金到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all. all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊一聊可卡因，但只是想让你们都知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集。所以我开始发现这里有一条主线。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we, are in possession of the thing.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid?
而我们仍在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，是因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要吗？还是你做个好人是因为你害怕？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast,
因为这是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。和我凯尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客中就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
《Learn the Hardway》。打开你的免费iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于父亲身份丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detestance. to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant.
这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。大批网络侦探花了很长时间才破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura O'Owold. Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think I've recently become quite cognizant of the fact that for the longest time, maybe the majority of my life, I have always been my own worst critic, the loudest voice in my head constantly drowning out all the the positive things in my life with negative predictions and self-doubt, kind of honing that spotlight in on everything that I'm doing wrong and ignoring all the good things. It even got to the point where I was becoming self-critical about how much I was self-critical. I would have these
女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。我想我最近清楚地意识到这样一个事实：在很长一段时间里，也许是我生命中的大部分时间里，我一直是自己最糟糕的批评者，我脑海中最响亮的声音不断用负面的预测和自我怀疑淹没了我生命中所有的积极事物，将聚光灯对准了我所做错的一切，而忽略了所有美好的事物。甚至到了后来，我对自己的批判程度本身也开始进行自我批判了。我会有这些
thoughts about how I was so stupid or had messed up and then an even louder voice would jump in and scold me for being like that. And neither of these voices was particularly, kind or helpful. So I've also become really fascinated with the why. As someone who is obviously really interested in psychology, it can be really hard to not seek an explanation for these kinds of behaviours and know that there is possibly a very logical, scientific, robust underpinning or kind of cause. I think it also minimises, I think, some of the shame and the personal blame that often accompanies self-criticism. And in this instance, there are so many explanations that explain why we are so hard on ourselves. So self-criticism, it's this tendency to evaluate ourselves
想法，觉得自己太蠢了或者搞砸了，然后一个更响亮的声音会跳出来，责备我为什么会这样。而这两种声音都不是特别善良或有帮助的。所以我也对“为什么”产生了浓厚的兴趣。作为一个对心理学真的很感兴趣的人，很难不去为这些行为寻求一种解释，并知道这背后可能存在着非常合乎逻辑、科学、稳健的基础或某种原因。我认为这也减少了我认为通常伴随自我批判而来的许多羞耻感和个人指责。在这种情况下，有太多的解释可以说明为什么我们对自己如此苛刻。因此，自我批判，就是这种倾向，即对我们自己进行
extremely harshly and to scrutinize our actions, our performance, our behavior, our body, our relationship, almost every aspects of our lives. It's distinct for. from self-awareness and the occasional self-policing in that it's a very automatic self-criticism self-blame and often feels like it's beyond our control and our default in any situation our default mental pattern is to actively blame ourselves and find our faults rather than see a situation objectively. B, it's excessively negative and maladaptive. It goes against our best interests and it actually undermines some of that helpful, productive behavior and coping mechanisms because this voice is so unnecessarily cruel. C is that we believe it. Unlike, I think,
极其严苛的评估，并仔细审视我们的行动、表现、行为、身体、关系，几乎是我们生活的方方面面。它不同于自我意识和偶尔的自我约束，因为它是一种非常自动的自我批评、自我指责，而且通常感觉超出了我们的控制，我们在任何情况下的默认模式、默认的心智模式是积极地责怪自己并找出自己的缺点，而不是客观地看待情况。B，它是过度负面的和适应不良的。它违背了我们的最佳利益，并且实际上破坏了一些有帮助的、富有成效的行为和应对机制，因为这个声音是如此不必要地残酷。C是我们相信它。不同于我认为
the occasional bad thought about others that we can dismiss or call ourselves. out for when we are hard on ourselves, the only person who can validate that belief is us. And so we tend to believe these negative thoughts. We tend to really take them on board because the voice, the opinion that is with us, the most in our lives is our own. So it's the one that we trust the most as well. And finally, D, it negatively impacts our lives. We may find ourselves skipping.
偶尔对别人产生的坏想法，我们可以不予理睬或指出自己不对，当我们对自己苛刻时，唯一能证实这种信念的人就是我们自己。因此，我们倾向于相信这些负面的想法。我们倾向于真正地接受它们，因为在我们生命中陪伴我们最多的声音、意见是我们自己的。所以它也是我们最信任的声音。最后D，它对我们的生活产生了负面影响。我们可能会发现自己逃避。
social events or going out, not putting ourselves out there, dating people who treat us poorly, or ruminating on our failures to a point where we can't move on and we do become stuck in that moment and stuck in that thought spiral. All of these things, I think, really detract from the now, but also from our reality and they make it incredibly hard to be gentle and to have a kind mind and a really soft internal space for us to thrive. All of this stems from what we call in pop psychology the inner critic, this sub-personality, this almost separate unconscious entity that judges and demeans us. The inner critic is the voice in our head telling us that we are worthless or shaming us.
社交活动或外出，不敢展现自我，与那些对我们不好的人约会，或者对我们的失败反复咀嚼，直到我们无法释怀，真正陷入那个时刻和那种思维怪圈中。所有这些事情，我认为，不仅真正减损了当下，也减损了我们的现实，它们让我们变得极其艰难，难以温柔以待，难以拥有一颗善良的心和一个真正柔软的内心空间来让我们蓬勃发展。这一切都源于我们在通俗心理学中所谓的“内在批评者”，这个次人格，这个几乎是独立的潜意识实体，它评判并贬低我们。内在批评者就是我们脑海中告诉我们自己毫无价值或让我们感到羞耻的声音。
And it's been theorized that it's actually a manifestation of our ego. more specifically what Freud called our super ego. So this super ego is something that we all kind of develop in early childhood. And it's that part of us that internalizes all the things that society wants us to do, all the lessons from our parents, all the scolding, and it automatically senses our behavior. It's this kind of unconscious mechanism for regulating our actions. And that's basically where the end of the enderogical. inner critic comes from. It's natural to have this impulse control, right? To have our ego override some of
有理论认为，这实际上是我们自我（ego）的一种表现。更具体地说，是弗洛伊德所谓的超我（super ego）。所以这个超我，是我们大家在幼儿时期都会发展出来的一种东西。它正是我们内心深处内化了社会希望我们做的一切事情、父母所有的教导、所有的责骂的那一部分，并且它会自动审视我们的行为。这是一种调节我们行为的潜意识机制。而这基本上就是内在批评者来源的地方。拥有这种冲动控制是自然的，对吧？让我们的自我去凌驾于某些
those extreme impulses, otherwise our society would kind of fall into anarchy. But when that inner critic is given too much control, instead of moderating certain behaviors, it absolutely paralyzes us. And I think one of the major ironies of self-criticism is that whilst we are constantly putting ourselves down and very carefully self-monering every little behavior for some perceived fault. We rarely level that same amount or severity of criticism against others. We have no problem celebrating our friends, accepting their failures, overlooking small things, hyping them up. But we cannot treat ourselves in the same way.
极端冲动之上，否则我们的社会就会陷入无政府状态。但当这个内在批评者被赋予了太多的控制权时，它不仅没有温和地调整某些行为，反而彻底让我们陷入瘫痪。我认为自我批判的一个主要讽刺之处在于，虽然我们不断地贬低自己，并且非常仔细地自我监控每一个微小的行为以寻找某些察觉到的缺点。我们却很少对别人施加同样数量或严重程度的批判。我们庆祝朋友、接受他们的失败、忽视小事情、为他们加油打气，都毫无问题。但我们却无法以同样的方式对待自己。
there's actually a very rational scientific explanation behind why this may be. Some researchers have proposed that we actually use different areas of our brain for judging others and judging ourselves because we are more attuned to our own behavior for survival, a lot less than the behavior of others. In one study conducted in the US, they actually examined this and what they did was they got participants to respond to a series of situations either from a place of self-criticism or self-reassurance. For example, they may have been told that they just received a rejection letter for a job and they were instructed to either speak kindly to themselves or to self-criticise.
这其实背后有一个非常理性的科学解释。一些研究人员提出，我们实际上使用大脑的不同区域来评判他人和评判自己，因为为了生存，我们对自己行为的调谐度要远远大于对他人行为的调谐度。在美国进行的一项研究中，他们实际上对此进行了检验，他们的做法是让参与者从自我批判或自我安慰的角度对一系列情况作出反应。例如，他们可能被告知他们刚刚收到了一封工作拒绝信，并被指示要么对自己说好话，要么进行自我批判。
Whilst they were doing this, they had them hooked up to an fMRI machine. This basically examines where blood is is kind of flowing in the brain and the logic is that when an area of the brain is active it needs more blood so therefore we can link the current behavior with the specific cortex or region and the results revealed this very significant association between self-criticism and the prefrontal cortex the part of our brain that is involved in regulating our thoughts and our emotions, but also in error detection and resolution as well as behavioral response inhibition, preventing us from doing things that are life-threatening or maybe embarrassing. And what this essentially concluded is that self-criticism as demeaning and awful as it is
在他们这样做的时候，研究人员让他们连接到功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）机器上。这基本上是检查血液在大脑中流动的位置，其逻辑是当大脑的一个区域处于活跃状态时，它需要更多的血液，因此我们可以将当前的行为与特定的皮层或区域联系起来。结果显示，自我批判与前额叶皮层之间存在着这种非常显著的关联，前额叶皮层是我们大脑中负责调节思想和情感的部分，但也参与错误检测和解决以及行为反应抑制，防止我们做出危及生命或可能令人尴尬的事情。这基本上得出的结论是，自我批判虽然听起来贬低人而且很糟糕，但
may actually have an evolutionary role in keeping us safe from things like dangerous repetitive behaviors and possibly life-threatening errors. However, when it gets out of control, the opposite is also true. That's just one kind of biological possibility amongst many. The other one has to do with temperament and personality. The leading theory around why we are so hard on ourselves is that self-criticism is a negative personality trait that we all innately possess. But this, this trait exists on a spectrum or a continuum. And those of us who possess this very loud inner critic, a measuring higher on self-criticism as a personality trait.
它实际上可能在保护我们免受危险的重复行为和可能危及生命的错误的侵害方面，具有演化上的作用。然而，当它失控时，情况则恰恰相反。这只是众多生物学可能性中的一种。另一种则与气质和性格有关。关于我们为什么对自己如此苛刻的主导理论是，自我批判是我们天生都具的一种消极人格特质。但这种特质存在于一个光谱或连续体上。而我们当中那些拥有这个非常响亮的内在批评者的人，作为一种人格特质，在自我批判上的得分更高。
Some of that comes from our temperament, maybe our DNA, you know, the mystery of where personality comes from, it's still a bit of a black box in psychology. But we do know that personality traits like self-criticism are a combination of nature, that being our genetics, and nurture, how we were raised. And that really leads into what I think is one of the biggest determining factors and reasons why some of us are so deeply self-critical. Adverse childhood experiences and childhood upbringing. We know so much more now about the kind of environment,
其中一些来自于我们的气质，也许是我们的DNA，你知道，性格来自哪里的谜团，在心理学中仍然是一个有点神秘的黑匣子。但我们确实知道，像自我批判这样的人格特质是先天（即我们的遗传）和后天（即我们是如何被抚养长大的）的结合。这就真正引出了我认为是最大的决定因素之一的原因，也是我们中的一些人为何如此深刻地进行自我批判的原因。逆境童年经历和童年教养。我们现在对这种环境了解得多了，
the kind of reassurance and love that children need to grow, especially compared to to a few generations ago. Studies have continuously shown across so many different areas that persistent parental criticism being constantly put down, even childhood bullying, instills what we would call a negative self-image and feelings of inherent inadequacy that continue into childhood. I think it used to be a very common belief that excessive criticism made a child stronger. And we know now that it doesn't. It just doesn't. And the reason some of us are so hard on ourselves likely originates from those early relationships
儿童成长所需的这种安心和爱，特别是与几代人相比。各项研究在许多不同领域不断表明，持续的父母批判、不断被贬低，甚至童年霸凌，都会灌输我们所说的消极自我形象和固有的不安全感，这些感觉会延续到童年。我认为过去人们普遍认为过度的批判会使孩子更坚强。但我们现在知道，并不会。它就是不会。我们中的一些人对自己如此苛刻的原因，很可能源于那些早期与照顾者的关系，
with caregivers and also with peers. So as children, we really internalize the words spoken to us, the language used against us, the treatment and how we incorporate those things as truth. Because we've never been told any differently. our only source of self-esteem is those around us. And when we're told that we're just not that smart, that we're ugly, that we're embarrassing, that we're worthless, these things become part of our belief system and part of our self-concept.
以及与同龄人的关系。所以在童年中，我们真正内化了对我们说的话、针对我们的语言、受到的对待，以及我们如何将这些事情作为真理加以吸收。因为我们从未听过不同的说法。我们唯一的自尊源泉就是周围的人。当有人告诉我们我们不够聪明、我们很丑、我们很尴尬、我们毫无价值时，这些事情就成为我们信念系统和自我概念的一部分。
Those early years are just so formative because it's during that time that our brains are laying those important neural pathways, they're understanding our relationship to others, and we really need the validation of our caregivers. We need a loving environment to feel good about ourselves. Or when we don't receive that, the consequences are lifelong. And it's not just this kind of emotional neglect or verbal scolding that's influential. When we face really high expectations from our family, you know, the need for perfect grades to do a few sports,
这些早期的岁月是如此具有塑造性，因为正是在这段时间里，我们的大脑正在铺设那些重要的神经通路，它们在理解我们与他人的关系，我们真的需要照顾者的肯定。我们需要一个充满爱的环境来对自己感觉良好。或者当我们没有得到这些时，后果将是终身的。不仅仅是这种情感忽视或言语责骂具有影响力。当我们面对来自家庭的极高期望时，你知道，需要完美的成绩去参加几项运动，
play a couple of musical instruments, to be excellent at all of them, Our standards for ourselves are incredibly out of proportion to what we're sustainably able to accomplish, but yet our sense of self has been hijacked for this need for approval and to be perfect, and we begin to internalize these expectations and self-police through excessive criticism. It's also influenced by how our parents or caregivers treat praise and love. In psychology, there is this important distinction between conditional and unconditional positive regard. So conditional positive regard means only giving someone love, giving them support, praise, warmth when they meet certain expectations or a set of conditions.
弹几种乐器，在所有这些方面都要出类拔萃，我们对自己设定的标准与我们可持续完成的能力完全不成比例，然而我们的自我意识却被这种对认可和完美的渴望所劫持，我们开始内化这些期望，并通过过度的批判进行自我监督。它还受到我们的父母或照顾者如何对待表扬和爱的影响。在心理学中，条件性积极关注和无条件积极关注之间存在着这样一个重要的区别。因此，条件性积极关注意味着只有当一个人符合某些期望或一组条件时，才给予他爱、支持、赞美、温暖。
Love is conditional on our ability to meet some standard. It's not freely given. In contrast, we have unconditional positive regard. And that means loving someone supporting them, regardless of whether they meet our expectations. We can see why conditional positive regard might be especially harmful as a child and also contribute to that self-criticism later in adulthood. If you learnt that love and warmth and support, all of which are basic human needs, were something to be earned, we become exceptionally good at blaming ourselves when we feel. fail and we're found undeserving. This kind of attitude teaches us that it is our actions that
爱是以我们满足某种标准的能力为条件的。它不是免费给予的。相比之下，我们有无条件积极关注。这意味着爱一个人，支持他们，无论他们是否符合我们的期望。我们可以看出，条件性积极关注作为孩子可能会特别有害，并且也会导致成年后那样的自我批判。如果你了解到爱、温暖和支持——所有这些都是人类的基本需求——是需要赢得的东西，那么当我们在感到失败时，我们就会变得非常擅长责怪自己，
caused us to be neglected, our actions that caused love and praise to be withheld. Something about us is wrong. Something about us is bad. And we carry that with us for a long, long time. Like I always say the words spoken to us in childhood become the words we speak to ourselves in adulthood. And I found that over and over again to be true, especially when we dive further into the psychology behind negative self-talk. That inner critic we were speaking of before, that voice can often sound a lot like the voice of our parents, or a judgmental friend, a bad ex-partner who put us down. Sometimes we don't realize how much we take on that apparent feedback of others, and they don't even need to be there or be saying those things for you to still think about the.
并发现自己不配得到。这种态度教会我们，是我们的行动导致我们被忽视，是我们的行动导致爱和赞美被剥夺。我们身上一定有什么地方出了问题。我们身上一定有什么不好的地方。而我们带着这些东西过了很久很久。就像我常说的，童年对我们说的话，成了我们成年后对自己说的话。我发现这反复被证明是真的，尤其是当我们更深入地探讨负面自言自语背后的心理学时。我们之前谈到的那个内在批评者，那个声音听起来往往很像我们父母的声音，或者一个评判我们的朋友，一个贬低我们的糟糕前任。有时我们没有意识到我们在多大程度上吸收了他人那种明显的反馈，甚至不需要他们在场或者说那些话，你依然会去想那些。
for you to still believe them. I remember back in, like, I don't know, a couple of years ago, I was dating this guy right when I started this podcast. I think I was like six months into recording. And he said to me one day, he was like, your podcast is so generic. I don't think anyone is ever going to relate to it. And his voice runs through my head almost every time I publish an episode.
你依然会去相信它们。我还记得，在好几年前吧，我刚开始做这个播客的时候，我在和一个男人约会。我想我当时录音大概有六个月了。有一天他对我说，他说，你的播客太大众化了。我觉得不会有人能产生共鸣的。每当我发布一集节目时，他的声音几乎都会在我脑海中回响。
Every time I do something different, every time I take a risk, no one's ever going to listen, no one's going to relate. But it's not his voice anymore, right? It's my voice now. Because even though, you know, I tried to shake it off at the time, I loved that person. I unfortunately trusted his opinion. And some part of me truly did believe him and took that so deeply and so to heart. And I think it was in the aftermath of that situation that I became particularly negative towards myself and and quite self-deprecating. Self-deprecation is an element of this that I think is really important to discuss,
每当我做一些不同的事情，每当我承担风险时，从来没有人会听，没有人会产生共鸣。但这已经不是他的声音了，对吧？现在是我的声音了。因为尽管，你知道，我当时试图摆脱它，我曾爱过那个人。我不幸地信任了他的意见。我内心某处确实相信了他，并把这话深深地铭记在心。我想正是在那种情况的余波中，我变得对特别消极，而且相当自嘲。自嘲是其中的一个元素，我认为这真的很重要去讨论，
because it has so many nuanced hidden links to self-criticism that are rarely spoken about. I think a lot of us like to use self-deprecating jokes and humor at our expense, and we think it's funny, right? It keeps us humble, and it might seem fairly harmless to call ourselves stupid in front of our friends, to kind of downgrade our achievements, but really that's actually just our inner critic, masking as being humorous or being humble. At the end of the day, it's still a negative self-evaluation, even if you're joking. There's another explanation proposed by researchers that we adopt self-deprecation in an attempt to
因为它与自我批判有着许多微妙的、隐藏的联系，而这些联系很少被提及。我想我们很多人都喜欢在自己身上开自嘲的玩笑和幽默，我们觉得这很好笑，对吧？它让我们保持谦逊，在朋友面前说自己笨，或者贬低自己的成就，似乎也相当无害，但实际上这只是我们的内在批评者，伪装成幽默或谦逊的样子。归根结底，这仍然是对自己的负面评估，即使你是在开玩笑。研究人员提出了另一种解释，即我们采用自嘲是为了
appear more modest and seem really agreeable, but I also find that we use this kind of language, these kinds of jokes, to protect our self-deprecation. esteem and our ego. If I already think that about myself, no one can use it against me. If I tear myself down first in a social situation, no one else can do it for me. It's an armor. It's a protective coping mechanism against the judgment of others. Sometimes I think we can even use it in some ways as a form of motivation. If you naturally have a negative self-perception, telling yourself you're awful, that you're going to fail. For some people, I think it can compel them to perform, to do better, to be better.
显得更加谦虚和随和，但我还发现我们使用这种语言、这种笑话来保护我们的自尊。尊严和自我。如果我已经在心里那样看待自己了，就没有人能以此来对付我。如果我在社交场合先贬低自己，其他人就无法代劳了。这是一副盔甲。这是一种针对他人评判的保护性应对机制。有时我想我们甚至可以在某种程度上将其用作一种动机。如果你天生具有消极的自我认知，告诉自己你很糟糕，你会失败。对某些人来说，我认为这可以强迫他们去表现，去做得更好，变得更好。
That's not a particularly sustainable way of motivating ourselves, though, because when we fail, we just reinforce that belief system. And when we succeed, it's a fluke. That voice isn't going anywhere. That's the cycle, right? It's like drinking more alcohol and expecting. it to help you become sober. Using self-criticism to push yourself or to eliminate your negative self-appraisal is not going to make you love yourself anymore. I want to discuss two other reasons
然而，这并不是一种特别可持续的激励自己的方式，因为当我们失败时，我们只会强化那种信念系统。而当我们成功时，那只是侥幸。那个声音不会消失。这就是循环，对吧？就像喝了更多的酒却期望它能帮。你变得清醒一样。用自我批判来推动自己或消除你的消极自我评估，并不会让你更爱自己。我想讨论另外两个原因
why we are so hard on ourselves after this break, as well as some of the best ways to kind of break out of this habit, to liberate us from that really nasty inner voice telling us will never be good enough, will never succeed. So all of that and more in just a second. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
在这次休息之后，我们为什么对自己如此苛刻，以及摆脱这种习惯的最佳方法，以将我们从那个真正讨厌的内在声音中解放出来，那个声音告诉我们永远不够好，永远不会成功。所以所有这些以及更多，就在转瞬之间。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的法则。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以抛开主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我们真的曾经相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些困难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己迎来柳暗花明。收听《2%》。即iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方上的T-W-O-P-e-r-s-e-n-t。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击利尔·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟利尔·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
畅谈80年代的可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊一聊可卡因，但只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集。所以我开始发现这里有一条主线。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games.
我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts，或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们仍在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，是因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要吗？还是你做个好人是因为你害怕？因为这是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose. On my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free. iHeartRadio app search learn the hard way and listen now in twenty twenty three former bachelor star clayton eckard found himself at the center of a paternity scandal the family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story this began a years long court battle to prove the truth you
和我凯尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客中就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中。打开你的免费。iHeartRadio应用搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于父亲身份丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你
doctored this particular test twice in so on correct i doctored the test ones it took an army of internet detectives to crack the case i wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars we're being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。大批网络侦探花了很长时间才破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over. until justice is served in Arizona.
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。这还没完。直到在亚利桑那州伸张正义。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There are two final psychological explanations that I want to discuss super briefly. The first is overthinking and over-analyzing, and the second is the power of social comparison as a fuel for our inner critic. If you listened to my episode on overthinking, it's an absolute favorite of mine, you'll know that it's sometimes possible to almost be too self-aware. And one of the consequences of that is being way too hard on ourselves, especially in relation to how we think others perceive us. Our brain tricks us into thinking that overthinking a scenario, examining every possible way we've messed up or done something wrong, will prepare us for the future.
在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。最后还有两个心理学解释我想极其简短地讨论一下。第一个是过度思考和过度分析，第二个是社会比较的力量，它成为了我们内在批评者的燃料。如果你听过我关于过度思考的那期节目，那绝对是我的最爱之一，你就会知道有时候几乎可能变得过于有自我意识。而这带来的后果之一就是对自己过于苛刻，尤其是在我们认为别人如何看待我们这方面。我们的大脑欺诈我们，让我们以为过度思考一个场景、检查我们搞砸了或做错事的每一种可能方式，会让我们为未来做好准备。
It will allow us to prepare for the judgment of others. It links to this fear of uncertainty, firstly, but also our innate evolutionary fear of the opinions of others. And I think that's really crucial. Others' opinions, they are important. Let's not discredit that entirely. Historically, we needed the approval of others to remain in the in-group to be accepted and therefore protected by the herd.
它将使我们能够为他人的评判做好准备。首先，这与对不确定性的恐惧有关，但也与我们对他人意见的内在演化恐惧有关。我认为这真的很关键。他安的意见，它们很重要。我们不要完全抹杀这一点。历史上，我们需要他安的批准才能留在内部群体中，从而被接纳并受到族群的保护。
And it's been proposed that our tendency for negative self-talk evolved from this instinct. This fascinating article, I'll leave it in the description. It's summed it up perfectly. Negative self-talk has served an evolutionary purpose. It comes from this evolutionary brain circuit in our brain. It's called the default mode network. And it helped people survive by aligning their interests with the group norms. We needed to follow the standards of the group.
有人提出，我们倾向于消极的自我对话就是从这种本能进化而来的。这篇精彩的文章，我会把它放在简介里。它完美地总结了这一点。消极的自我对话有着进化的目的。它源于我们大脑中的这种进化大脑回路。它被称为默认模式网络。它通过将个人的利益与群体规范保持一致，来帮助人们生存。我们需要遵循群体的标准。
group. We need to constantly monitor our behavior so that if we step out of line, we can correct ourselves before we're ostracized. That is why the default mode is self-directed and critical. It's trying to keep you alive. There's also that element of social comparison. Our inner critic loves, absolutely loves using others as fuel for our own insecurities. How do I know that I'm a terrible person? Well, look at her. She's obviously incredible and kind. And since I'm not like her, I must be awful. How do I know I'm a failure? Well, look at all that they've achieved. Look at them. How do I know that I'm unattractive? Well, she is beautiful. I don't look like her. So I must be unattractive. I must be ugly. I think that the important thing is to realize that the existence of someone
群体。我们需要不断监控自己的行为，这样如果我们出格了，就能在被排挤之前纠正自己。这就是为什么默认模式是自我导向且具有批判性的。它在试图让你活下去。这里还有社会对比的因素。我们的内在批判者喜欢、绝对喜欢用别人作为自己不安全感的燃料。我怎么知道自己是个糟糕的人？你看她。她显然非常出色且善良。既然我不如她，那我一定糟透了。我怎么知道自己是个失败者？好吧，看看他们取得的成就。看看他们。我怎么知道自己没有吸引力？好吧，她很漂亮。我长得不像她。所以我一定没有吸引力。我一定很丑。我认为重要的一点是要意识到，某个
else's value and success is not evidence of our inadequacy. Those two things are completely separate. Our value and their value are not mutually exclusive. No one is living the same way. And beyond that, I think an important thing to remember is that no one is looking at you as closely or judging you as closely as you are judging yourself. Our inner critic benefits from us feeling like we're at the center of the universe. because that just adds weight to how important our actions and behaviours are and therefore how perfect they need to be. That's not true. No one is looking at you. I promise we are all just as self-obsessed as the next person. And there's this thought experiment I always like to do when
别人的价值和成功并不能证明我们的不足。这两者是完全独立的。我们的价值和他们的价值并不是互斥的。没有人生活在完全相同的轨道上。除此之外，我认为需要记住重要的一点是，没有人像你自己那样密切关注你或评判你。我们的内在批判者让我们觉得自己是宇宙的中心，这让我们受益匪浅。因为这只会增加我们的行动和行为有多重要，因此它们需要有多完美的份量。这不是真的。没有人看着你。我向来保证，我们大家都和旁人一样自恋。每当我开始真正担心和过度思考别人的看法时，我总是喜欢做一个思想实验
I start to really worry and overthink about the opinions of others. And that is, when was the last time you noticed a mistake someone else made. When was the last time that you cringed at someone else? And what was that person's name? What were they wearing? What does that say about them? And how often do you actually think about it? Genuinely, how often?
那就是，你最后一次注意到别人犯错是什么时候。你最后一次对别人感到尴尬是什么时候？那个人叫什么名字？他们穿什么？这说明了他们什么？你实际上多久想一次？真心实意地说，多久一次？
Because if you're thinking about someone else's mistakes a lot, that's really not their problem. That's a you problem. And the same goes for other people who are spending their hours judging you. That is not your problem. And exacerbating or heightening those opinions in your mind is only going to increase your susceptibility and I guess the frequency by which you are hard on yourself. So how do we stop doing this? How do we rein in that pesky inner voice? That can feel especially hard. I want to give credit to people who are like, I don't know if I can do that because
因为如果你总是想着别人的错误，那真的不是他们的问题。那是你自己的问题。那些花时间评判你的其他人也是如此。那不是你的问题。在脑海中加剧或放大这些意见，只会增加你的易感性，以及我猜你对自己严厉的频率。那么我们如何停止这样做呢？我们如何控制那个讨厌的内在声音？这可能会让人感觉格外困难。我想向那些觉得“我不知道我能不能做到”的人表达敬意，因为
You know, when we understand the childhood roots and the roots in so many historical events, childhood bullying, things that we cannot change, it's really hard to feel like we have agency or control over this thought pattern. But I do believe that we can change our negative self-perception. Those are our thoughts. We should feel empowered and able to control them. Additionally, I think when we think good things about ourselves, it kind of makes us this like amazing person.
你知道的，当我们了解童年的根源以及许多历史事件的根源、童年的欺凌、我们无法改变的事情时，真的很难感觉到我们对这种思维模式拥有代理权或控制力。但我确实相信我们可以改变我们的消极自我认知。那是我们的想法。我们应该感到有力量并能够控制它们。此外，我认为当我们对自己的看法良好时，它会让我们成为一个如此了不起的人。
Like I don't know if there is a theory behind this. Like I haven't really looked into it. So take it with a grain of salt. But I think anecdotally, I've found that when I think better things about myself, I think better things about others. I just kind of have this like this glow, this energy to me that I find really attractive and that I would hope others do as well because you already see yourself in a better light. You feel more respect for yourself.
就像我不知道这背后是否有理论支持。就像我没有真正深入研究过一样。所以请不要全盘接受。但我凭经验发现，当我对自己有更好的看法时，我对别人也会有更好的看法。我身上只散发着这种光芒、这种能量，我觉得这非常有吸引力，我希望别人也会这么觉得，因为你已经以更好的眼光看待自己了。你对自己的尊重增加了。
and you demand that respect from others. So I do think it's really critical that we step through exactly how we can stop judging ourselves, being mean to ourselves and putting ourselves down. I think our initial instinct, when we initially recognize ourselves in a negative thought spiral, is to ironically be more self-critical to shame ourselves. Criticizing our self-criticism comes from that misguided belief that you have to do something in response to it. And since we've formed a habit around judgment, our knee-jerk reaction to counteract the self-criticism is to just amp it up, to just add more fuel to the fire. I think
你也会要求别人给予这种尊重。所以我认为，我们逐步剖析如何停止评判自己、对自己刻薄以及贬低自己，真的是至关重要的。我认为我们最初的本能，当我们最初发现自己陷入消极思维的漩涡时，具有讽刺意味的是，我们会对自己更加批判，感到羞耻。对我们的自我批判进行批判，源于那种误解，即你必须对它做出某种回应。既然我们已经养成了评判的习惯，我们对抗自我批判的膝跳反应就是将其放大，给火上浇油。我认为
you can either treat your inner critic as an enemy, you can treat them as an ally, or as neither, as just a thing, it's just something that exists. And I think that taking away its power by detaching it from our identity, we regain the most control. So you need to create kind of a psychological distance from your self-criticism by personifying it. Give it a name. Give it a feature. Give it a face. Maybe call it the little devil. It could be anything. Just give it a name. Treat it like it's neither an enemy or a friend. It's just this little creature that exists in your mind who wonders from room to room, you know, a case. Occasionally it pops up, but you know what's around and it's not scary, and you can acknowledge it and say hi, be like, hi little creature, hi little devil, whatever you want to call it, and then ignore it. It's just like a little critter that lives in your house. This article in the Harvard Business Review, which is one of my go-to places for finding some of these studies, an amazing resource. If you are a psychology student, I will say. But it explains why this personification is so powerful.
你可以把你的内在批判者当作敌人，你可以把它当作盟友，或者两者都不是，只是一种事物，它就是某种存在。我认为通过将其从我们的身份中剥离来夺走它的力量，我们可以重新获得最大的控制权。因此，你需要通过拟人化你的自我批判来与它保持某种心理距离。给它起个名字。给它一个特征。给它一张脸。也许叫它小恶魔。它可以是任何东西。只需给它起个名字。像对待既不是敌人也不是朋友一样对待它。它只是你脑海中存在的一个小生物，在房间里走来走去，你知道的，一个案件。偶尔它会出现，但你知道它就在附近，而且并不可怕，你可以承认它并打招呼，比如，嗨，小生物，嗨，小恶魔，随你怎么称呼它，然后忽略它。它就像一只住在你家里的宠物。这篇《哈佛商业评论》上的文章，是我寻找其中一些研究的首选地方之一，是一个了不起的资源。如果你是一名心理学学生，我要说的是。但它解释了为什么这种拟人化如此强大。
we name our inner critic, this leverages a concept called cognitive diffusion. And it's a process by which we separate ourselves and our identity from our thoughts. So diffusion is shown to reduce discomfort. It reduces stress, reduces particularly stress around negative thoughts. And it also promotes psychological flexibility or the capacity to be aware and open and to adapt to your changing emotional circumstances. You know, it's not, your thoughts do not own you. That's what cognitive diffusion says. Your thoughts are just a thought.
我们给内在批判者命名，这利用了一个名为认知解离的概念。这是一个我们将自己和我们的身份与我们的想法分开的过程。因此，解离已被证明可以减轻不适。它减少压力，尤其减少围绕消极想法的压力。它还促进心理灵活性，即意识到、开放并适应不断变化的的情绪环境的能力。你知道，不是的，你的想法不拥有你。这就是认知解离所说的。你的想法只是一种想法。
There's also this incredible theory in psychology called radical self-compassion. I could talk about this idea for hours. It's possibly my new favorite theory. And it initially arose as just radical compassion. And it was used to describe a specific type of empathy towards other people. that this philosopher can lamp it, he suggested that loving others unconditionally kind of has a healing element to it. When we love others deeply, we can heal them. We can alleviate what they're going through. And when we direct that compassion and love towards ourselves, we can heal ourselves
心理学中还有一个令人难以置信的理论，叫做激进自我同情。我可以谈论这个想法几个小时。这可能是我最喜欢的新理论。它最初只是作为激进同情心出现的。它被用来描述对其他人的特定类型的同情。哲学家肯·兰伯特（Ken Lambert）提出，无条件地爱别人具有某种治愈的元素。当我们深深地爱别人时，我们可以治愈他们。我们可以减轻他们正在经历的事情。当我们把这种同情和爱转向我们自己时，我们可以治愈我们自己
and stop being so hard on ourselves. We do this by emulating the kind of love we would typically receive from others and giving that love to ourselves, redirecting it. We don't need to earn it. Our self-compassion is radical and freely given. Think about it in terms of the five love languages to kind of structure our thinking. So those are words of affirmation, quality time, receiving gifts, acts of service, and physical touch. You need to adapt and adopt those love languages and direct them towards yourself.
并不再对自己那么严厉。我们通过效仿我们通常从别人那里得到的爱并把这种爱给予我们自己、重新定向来做到这一点。我们不需要去赢得它。我们的自我同情是激进而无条件给予的。从五种爱语的角度来思考它，以构建我们的思考方式。这些是肯定的言辞、优质的相处时间、接受礼物、服务的行动和身体接触。你需要适应并采用这些爱语，并将它们指向你自己。
speak kind words say two things to yourself every day that are positive tell yourself that you are proud of how far you've come tell others that you are proud of yourself as you would say that you are proud of your friends or your family members I would also say make time to spend with your thoughts my favorite activity is solo dates and one of my friends Claude who was on the show recently shared this amazing practice that they have where once a month they go to a different Italian restaurant in Sydney and get a glass of wine, a pastor, and they journal about how they're feeling and where they see the next month going. That is self-love. That is self-compassion and it counteracts that negative self-image. You know, that's adapt to those further. Buy yourself a little trait every now and again.
说些贴心的话，每天对自己说两件积极的事情。告诉自己，你为自己所取得的成就感到自豪；告诉别人，你为自己感到自豪，就像你会说你为你的朋友或家人感到自豪一样。我还要说，腾出时间与你的想法共度时光。我最喜欢的活动是独自约会，最近上过节目的我的朋友克劳德（Claude）分享了一个了不起的做法：他们一个月去一次悉尼不同的意大利餐厅，喝一杯酒，吃一份意面，并写下他们的感受以及他们认为下个月的发展方向。这就是自爱。这就是自我同情，它能对抗消极的自我形象。你知道的，进一步适应这些。时不时地给自己买一点好东西。
Not because you've worked hard for it, not because you've been quote unquote good, but because you deserve to have nice things. You deserve to feel happy. Make your bed in the morning, clean your room in the evening because you know that your future self will thank you the same way that you would want others to do upon you with acts of service. You can do upon to yourself. And finally, give yourself physical touch. This sounds really strange sometimes when I explain it to people, but touch actually activates our parasympathetic nervous system. That is what helps us exit flight or flight mode and it helps us feel safe and calm. And we can physically self-souve and create that same reaction by doing things like placing one hand over our heart
不是因为你为此努力工作过，不是因为你“表现好”，而是因为你值得拥有美好的事物。你值得感到快乐。早上整理床铺，晚上打扫房间，因为你知道未来的自己会感谢你，就像你希望别人用服务的行动对待你一样。你也可以这样对待自己。最后，给自己身体接触。当我向人们解释这一点时，这有时听起来真的很奇怪，但接触实际上会激活我们的副交感神经系统。这有助于我们摆脱战斗或逃跑模式，并帮助我们感到安全和冷静。我们可以通过做一些事情来身体自我安抚并创造同样的反应，比如把一只手放在心上
and the other hand over our shoulder and just giving a tight squeeze or caressing our own face. That is radical self-compassion. It's saying you don't need to earn the love that you give yourself. It is freely given. It is yours. If you don't see how this relates to minimizing your inner critic, I want to explain a little bit further. We know that one of the root causes of being hard on ourselves is feeling like you are undeserving of love or empathy or seeking validation from others because, you know, you're of childhood deprivation or an intense pressure to prove yourself or bullying. But when you institute radical self-compassion, you give yourself the permission that maybe others haven't given you to feel good, to celebrate yourself, to be loved.
另一只手放在肩膀上，紧紧地拥抱自己或抚摸自己的脸。这就是激进的同情心。它在说，你不需要赢得你给予自己的爱。它是无条件给予的。它是你的。如果你不明白这与尽量减少你的内在批判者有什么关系，我想进一步解释一下。我们知道，对自己严厉的根本原因之一是觉得自己不值得拥有爱或同情，或者从别人那里寻求验证，因为，你知道的，你经历了童年剥夺、证明自己的巨大压力或欺凌。但是，当你建立激进的自我同情时，你给了自己别人可能没有给过你的许可，去感觉良好，去庆祝自己，去被爱。
And before we ask others to do that for us, we need to find a way to reach that conclusion and deliver that feeling on an individual level. And there have been so many experiments that have shown self-compassion reduces the negative effects of shame and self-criticism. And it's even created its own type of therapeutic practice called compassion focus therapy. So there you go. Look into that as well. I find that is so fascinating. Some other strategies are to do a bit of a mental and social detox. Sometimes it's the things in our environment that are causing us to be excessively negative. Maybe a particularly strained toxic friendship or a bad habit that is bringing forward a lot of guilt. So do a bit of a stock of your life.
在我们要求别人为我们这样做之前，我们需要找到一种方法来得出这个结论，并在个体层面上传递这种感觉。有太多的实验表明，自我同情可以减少羞耻感和自我批判的负面影响。它甚至催生了它自己的治疗实践，叫做同情焦点疗法。所以你看。也可以研究一下。我觉得这太迷人了。其他一些策略是进行一点精神和社交排解。有时是我们环境中的事物导致我们变得过于消极。也许是一种特别紧张的有毒友谊或带有很多内疚的坏习惯。所以对你的生活进行一番盘点。
What feels good? What doesn't? What is creating a negative thought spiral? And is it possible to eliminate this from your life? One of the things that my therapist actually said to me as well is like, what, and what days do you feel the best about yourself? And what are you doing on those days? What are you wearing on those days?
什么感觉好？什么感觉不好？是什么在引发消极的思维漩涡？是否有可能将这些从你的生活中消除？实际上，我的治疗师对我说过的一件事也是，什么，你在哪几天对自己的感觉最好？你在那些日子里在做什么？你在那些日子里穿什么？
And on what days are you feeling bad about yourself? What do you do on those days? What are you wearing? Who are you interacting with? What are you eating? all of those little things really do contribute to our self-image on a day-to-day basis. Also, further to that idea kind of of not treating self-criticism like an enemy, another way to bring it under our control is to almost counterintuitively
在哪几天你对自己的感觉不好？你在那些日子里做什么？你穿什么？你在和谁互动？你在吃什么？所有这些小事确实都对我们日常的自我形象有所贡献。此外，除了不把自我批判当作敌人这一想法之外，将其置于我们控制之下的另一种方法是，几乎有些反直觉地
give ourselves the occasional permission to be a bit mean. You can't always quit cold turkey, especially if that negative self-talk is a deeply ingrained thought pattern. So instead, give yourself five minutes a day to think those negative thoughts if you really can't break out of them. Contain the habit. And then you can be like, okay, I gave myself five minutes, I did that, I let myself feel bad, I let myself be cruel, and that part of my day is done.
偶尔给自己一点许可去变得有点刻薄。你不能总是冷火鸡式地一下子戒掉，特别是如果那种消极的自我对话是一种根深蒂固的思维模式的话。因此，如果你真的无法摆脱它们，相反，给自己每天五分钟的时间去想那些消极的想法。控制这个习惯。然后你可以说，好吧，我给了自己五分钟，我做到了，我让自己感觉不好，我让自己变得残忍，我这一天的那部分就结束了。
Those thoughts are going to remain in that moment. and my life is going to go on. It's also important to just be neutral towards your thoughts, especially as they relate to your perceived failures or imperfections. A thought is just a thought. It's not the truth. You can think it and you don't have to believe it. It can just exist.
那些想法将留在那一刻。而我的生活将继续。对自己的想法保持中立也很重要，特别是当它们与你认为的失败或不完美有关时。一个想法只是一个想法。它不是真相。你可以这样想，而不必相信它。它可以只是存在。
That was a really powerful realization for me, not just in relation to my tendency to be hard on myself, but also how I treat self-doubt and anxiety and even body dysmorphia and insecurity. Just because I think something about myself does not make it true. And I think all of those practices are incredibly liberating. We deserve to have a peaceful mind. I think we can be our own worst enemy.
对我来说，这是一个非常强大的认识，不仅与我对自己严厉的倾向有关，还与我如何对待自我怀疑、焦虑甚至身体变形和不安全感有关。仅仅因为我对自己的看法并不意味着它是真的。我认为所有这些做法都非常具有解放性。我们应该拥有一个平静的头脑。我认为我们自己可能是自己最大的敌人。
We can really take on the feedback of others and make it our own and criticize as a way to almost protect ourselves but also to humble ourselves. and to make ourselves feel less than. You are not the only one, I promise. I think that this is highly common in this generation, especially because we have so many points to elicit social comparison. Like I talk about the prominence of social media all the time, but it used to be that we could only really view those in our community
我们真的可以接受别人的反馈并将其据为己有，把批评作为一种几乎可以保护我们自己，但同时也让我们感到卑微的方式。并让我们觉得自己不如别人。我保证，你不是唯一一个。我认为这在这代人中非常普遍，特别是因为我们有太多的点来引发社会比较。就像我一直谈论社交媒体的显赫地位一样，过去我们真的只能看到我们社区里的人
and in our surroundings. And then we had the internet, but it was always in one corner of the house on the computer. And now suddenly we can walk around every day with a phone. glued to our hands, and if at any point we want to feel bad, we want to judge ourselves, we can find a million ways to do that. We can look at a million different pictures of other people's perfect lives and perfect bodies and perfect jobs and just feel inherently really crappy. So I don't think that that is forever. I think that's something that we can act out against
以及我们周围的环境。然后我们有了互联网，但它总是在屋子里的一个角落的电脑上。现在突然间我们可以每天拿着手机到处走动，粘在我们的手上，如果我们在任何时候想感觉不好，想评判自己，我们可以找到一百万种方法来做到这一点。我们可以看一百万张关于别人完美生活、完美身材和完美工作的不同照片，然后觉得自己生来就很糟糕。所以我不认为那是永远的。我认为这是我们可以反抗的事情
and we can push back against. And I just hope that this episode gave you some valuable insight, firstly in psycho education, but also some tips and some strategies. Like I said, radical self-compassion, life-changing. So life-changing. Cognitive diffusion, also incredible. So this episode was definitely one that I really enjoyed researching and putting together. As always, if you enjoyed it and you think someone in your life might enjoy it as well, please feel free to send them a link to this episode. You never know what they'll take from it. Also, again, I'm going to plug the Patreon because I would love to see more of my loyal listeners over there. You get access to you know, bonus episodes, bonus content and newsletter, all of the episode transcripts. You can vote
我们可以对此进行回击。我只希望这一集能给你一些有价值的见解，首先是心理教育，还有一些小贴士和策略。就像我说的，激进的自我同情，能改变人生。太改变人生了。认知解离，也令人难以置信。所以这一集绝对是我非常享受研究和整理的一集。像往常一样，如果你喜欢它，并且认为你生活中的某个人也可能会喜欢它，请随时向他们发送这一集链接。你永远不知道他们会从中吸取什么教训。另外，再次说明，我要宣传Patreon，因为我很乐意看到更多我的忠实听众去那里。你可以访问你知道的，奖励剧集、奖励内容和时事通讯、所有剧集文字记录。你可以投票
on upcoming episodes, free merch, and it's as little as $1 a month. So it goes a long way when a lot of people contribute. I'll leave a link in the episode description. And please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now. If you did enjoy this episode, we will be back next week. I will see you then. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games.
关于即将到来的剧集，免费周边，而且每月只需1美元。所以当很多人贡献时，它会大有帮助。我会在剧集简介中留下一个链接。如果你真的很喜欢这一集，请随时在苹果、Spotify或你现在正在收听的任何地方留下五星级评价。如果你喜欢这一集，我们下周会回来。到时见。嘿，过得怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难地学习》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人卡尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不安全的诚实对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的获得执照的专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套或盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难地学习》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你把这个特定的测试篡改了两次才出售，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·兰吉尼（Michael Ranjini）。我的脑子都要炸了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《被困的爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被困的爱》播客。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些困难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听TWA%。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在Iheart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是人类制作的。本集目前没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子以发表评论。